news of US President Donald Trump's
so-called deal of the century reached on
bilal 9500 kilometers away here in
northern Gaza after all this is where
it's all about but she's more concerned
with providing for her six children
cooking gas is the latest shortage so
she has to cook outside using collected
wood people want to be able to feed
their children to have a dignified life
and a future for their kids some people
went out to protest against the deal
sure but what's more important for us is
better living conditions hopefully one
day things will get better but there is
no sign of that Israel's blockade of
Gaza is in to its 13th year the water
supply is sporadic as is electricity
sanitation is an issue and there is
widespread poverty and unemployment
people need solutions they need money
they need jobs to be able to provide for
their families everyone has taken out
loans and can't repay them I've only had
one client since this morning around 2
million people are stuck here in the
Gaza Strip a tiny shutoff piece of land
where no one can leave without Israel or
Egypt's permission and most people have
never left at all the United Nations
issued a report eight years ago
predicting that Gaza would become quote
unlivable by 2020 while it is 2020 and
still no political solution in sight I'm
Judd shower tells me that this plan
offered no new ideas and nothing that
the Palestinians could take as a
starting point to work with this will
lead more and more for more anger for
more also reactions from the different
political groups and at the same time
from the individuals in Gaza Strip
there's been a slight increase in
cross-border tensions in the last few
days a cycle of escalation and shaky
truces that everyone here has had to
become used to humble our iterates what
so many others have told us too people
are fed up with their leaders
I blame the officials who are sitting on
their chairs and don't care about us
even her master's and care about us
they're enjoying their good lives in
their homes while our children can't get
food Gaza needs a long-term political
solution one that allows freedom of
movement and the building of
infrastructure needed to sustain two
million people one that creates jobs and
opportunities people tell us they just
want to be able to breathe but what this
so-called deal of the century does
manage to do is highlight just how very
far off that political solution is
Stephanie Decker al Jazeera Gaza